ouais voici eddy mitchell
alors rêver n'est-ce pas venu pour rien
qu'il ya d'abord un cd un dvd
la tournée 2003-2004 le frenchie tour
110 dates dont 29 olympia et ensuite ya
un livre un album illustré de 200 photos
un texte de sam bernett qui raconte
votre vie du rockeur au crooner voilà
alors c'est un livre très intéressant
c'est moi ce que j'aime en fait dans les
bio des stars c'est l'enfance voilà
alors naissance en 42 du côté de la
place des fêtes dans le 19e
arrondissement
vos parents s'appelle lucienne et robert
s'énerve
non mais ça fait un peu pile de l'oust
usées aux chenilles sienne et robert
gillette et marcel et oui je sais c'est
un peu ça la soeur s'appelle gisèle et
le frère s'appelle tiers vous êtes le
petit dernière le petit gars tu es petit
clown un oui le petit chouchou quoi un
petit chouchou de la paix loin oui mais
alors vous voulez pas sur l'or dans
cette famille le soir pour dîner vous
dit on on met un morceau de pain dans un
bol de vin rouge quoi c'est quand même
été ça ah ça c'est l'été à l'hiver c'est
quoi une bonne grosse soupe non oui et
puis la fin du mois se termine le 15 h
devant le chalet la cour votre père
héros discret de la résistance mais qui
se retrouve pas ma bosse et à la ratp
quoi comme votre père travaille la nuit
le jour il a le temps de s'occuper de
bruit vous amène voir des western des
thrillers des péplums dans les cinémas
de quartier
il vous amène voir des combats de catch
et c'est lui finalement kivu forme
complètement quoi ah oui donc totalement
et puis même au niveau au niveau du
tract sûrs de ce que mon père est très
très très ouvert 10
de tout ça l'est de aussi bien de
puisqu'à l'époque le
la grande star du polar c'était plus
tard chez mais aussi bien peu plus tard
chemin en passant par sartre enfin tous
vendus donc vous lisiez les livres de
peter celle et vous allez voir la môme
vert de gris avec un ris constantine
ouais c'est toute une culture c'est vrai
bah oui oui oui c'est important c'est
bien mais alors vous n'avez pas beaucoup
aux lycéens faut bien le dire un vous
préférez draguer fumée glander un succès
plutôt ça votre choix sur vos achats
c'est quand même alors dans la famille
des dix mises à part votre père qui
travaille la ratp la nuit
tout le monde travaille au crédit
lyonnais donc vous vous retrouvez est
coursier à l'agencé chez lieu drouot
bientôt vous êtes viré parce qu'en tant
que course évidemment vous barrez sur la
petite mobylette et vous allez tout
faire sauf sauf du travail et et
finalement vous êtes viré mais cette
expérience vous permet de découvrir ce
qu'on appelle le triangle d'or c'est à
dire entre les grands boulevards le
square de la trinité la rue richelieu et
là vous rencontrer deux autres glandeurs
passionné de rock qui sont johnny
hallyday et les troncs et jacques
dutronc est ce que je trouve assez
extraordinaire quand même c'est cette
rencontre quoi les trois plus grands
jouer ensemble à l'adolescence c'est
très bizarre quand même un merveilleux
et de surtout de merveilleux c'est qu'on
soit resté non seulement en très bons
termes mais qu'on soit vraiment des amis
je proposerai pas rencontré dick rivers
marrant la vie j'étais à nice si je
connais bien c'est ça et lui il était
une fois et alors bientôt vous découvrez
le golf drouot qui deviendra le berceau
du rock français
nous quand on l'a connu c'était un
endroit pour vieille dame qui me prendre
le thé ce qu'a fait l'objet d'un arrêt
au dessus du café d'angleterre c'était
vraiment un mini golf golf miniature
donc quatre centres où l'on sait rien
c'est rien alors ce qui est drôle c'est
votre première rencontre ça je savais
pas avec jean philippe smet donc futur
géniale idée il vous piquent des disques
c'est vrai nom mais de ne pas coté pas
très loin de vittavi des march est une
une surprise party comme l'ont dit et
lanka bon j'avais à mes délices comme
tous les gamins comme tout faux nous
étions et en partant quand ça se termine
faut lire à embarquer et les miens je
les trouvais pas et avec mon camarade
johnny qui lui les avait confiés aux
concierges ont dix ans je repasserai
répondent plus tard voilà et a voulu
coller au mur quand même récupérer
votive attendait c'était les premiers 45
tours du nouveau un sens face au but
donc entre johnny et vous ça a commencé
par un parent baston pour baston pas
bien méchant brega et puis pourquoi tu
aimes ça bah parce que moi j'aime ça et
là ce qu on a parlé de choses beaucoup
plus importantes que nous parle du
tronquay l'époque est un vrai dandy
chapeau enfoncé jusqu'aux oreilles
imperméable cintrée à la taille
oui c'est vrai qu'il avait un côté on
l'appelait liasse tonderai car il se
tenait exprès pour le gag se tenait
toujours bouter avec un imperméable et à
l'époque il avait des foyers triple
triple dr triple foyer comme ça et quand
il variait on appelait ça l'opération
gitane
ouais c'était avant sa métamorphose
parce qu'après après c'est devenu le
playboy qu'il est toujours assez
l'époque que vous récoltez le surnom de
schmoll une fixette les la valise parce
qu'elle avait un d'ezanville énorme part
et ils n'ont pas franchement non elle
avait une intelligence très proche d'un
maillage est d'ailleurs le truc drôle
c'est que je les croisais il ya peu de
temps on n'entend rien il réalisa les
revues la veille les 3es à saint tropez
- je l'embrassé fc bâle à son poste et
j'ai même pas eu le temps du à liart
bonjour la malice quand ça va bien on
est parti alors à l'époque vous formez
votre premier groupe qui s'appelle les
five rocks 1
mais quand il ya le premier passage sur
europe 1 vous découvrez vous appelez les
chaussettes noires parce qu'elle avait
un deal entre votre maison
c'est un marchand de chaussettes
téléchargez le stand ce thème ouais et
bon j'ai appris par la radio j'ai appelé
les chaussettes noires
franchement ça vous a fait quoi se
faisait humilier vous appelez les
chaussettes main c'était un peu dur
quand même
c'était même pas humiliation c'était
consternation maintenant je vends ce
tout ça était pas important parce que on
pensait qu'on avait fait un vrai fait un
disque ans c'était amusant et puis non
qu'on garde la délinquance l'étape et
c'est vrai que c'est vrai non nous avons
aujourd'hui une fatwa
dans tous les cas le succès est immédiat
vous avez du succès tout de suite avec
tu parles trop bebopalula daniela et
vous vendez en deux ans deux millions de
disques hommes sable à l'époque c'était
c'était énorme
besson
mais bon vous prenez ça comme ça mais
c'est quand même extraordinaire oui mais
elle peut contrôler c'est normal
ouais non plus le truc drôle c'est que
c'est vrai ah bon c'est bien c'est
formidable puis on ne veut pas enfin on
changerait pas bien compris le problème
c'est que vous partez à l'armée et
d'eads dont on va prendre faire si on
n'a pas le temps après d'accord alors
soyez soyez tranquilles sur vivre
émergerait de la star du même nom
à un moment il faut qu'on leur rende
leur est d'accord voilà alors après vous
faites quelques succès il ya toujours un
coin qui me rappelle s'il n'en reste
qu'un alice enfin des débuts de votre
carrière solo dont il ya comme une
longue traversée du désert j'ai géré vu
ça en lisant ce bouquin je me souvenais
pas ça va mal il ya une période comme ça
qui dure 4 5 ans où vous êtes quand même
dur
quatre ans est à la ramasse quand même
un ouais même pensé un moment
il envisage même de reformer le show
s'est enfin vous voulez pas un embauches
en france et là c'était en mai on vous
le propose
oui monsieur maintenant s'ils vont dire
à quel point ça allait mal oui non mais
c'est vrai que je vendais très très peu
de disques et
et que ce qui faisait peur c'est que les
anciens disques qui était reproposer en
compilant sont souvent les mieux prêt
oui le best-of des chaussettes noires
sans répondait mieux vaut 10 c'est
terrible ça ça c'est oui c'est ce qui
arrive à dave tous les ans vous me direz
un bail
il n'était pas dans les chaussettes
noires non à ce moment là vous faites
une émission est une émission de radio
qui s'appelle en attendant que ça se
passe donc c'est bien la preuve que vous
aviez le sentiment qui ne marche pas non
plus ne me guilbert cependant c'était
enfin c'est drôle se pendre ou s'est
créé à lille qui s'appelle au fond du
trou immense non mais ça va pas du tout
alors décourage nous vivier de quoi à
l'époque j'ai tourné où j'avais pas
envie d'aller d'ailleurs je tourne vers
les pays de l'est roumanie machin tout
ça est que le chou farci tout ce qu'on
aime bien
et je gagnais très bien ma vie mais je
n'étais pas très drôle moi non et là
c'est le drame
ben non justement laurent c'est le grand
retour
m
tél
le
dedans
mon salon
il
de l'odeur
enfin
sa peau
ce vieux moulin je vais
dieu moi
le promeneur
vos patins
oui
non
bon
le montrer
avec sa très vite ample
jlt version qu'on extrait du cd le
frenchie tort donc ça c'est des trucs
que vous avez chanté il ya
elsa exactement non non non il ya du
nouvel an fin mai quand même si des
interprétations d'aujourd'hui mais sur
ses potes voilà cmj mais j'aime bien
c'est bien voir alors donc elle frenchy
tours il ya le cd le dvd alors le dvd
c'est un double dvd
les ias 23 titres sur le sur le premier
vous me regardez les titres sur le
premier et le deuxième c'est un bonus
avec pierre lescure michel serrault
artouz j'ai pas vu et moi on m'a raconté
non financiers dix inédits il ya des
reprises de chansons absolument
incroyable de chanson française comme
j'aime parler au mois de mai où un
emprunt de la balle
alors on va voir à quoi ça ressemble
vous pouvez regarder votre caméra et
dire magnéto serge